in england the government has revoked
plans to introduce vaccine passports to
enter nightclubs and also mass
gatherings after the initiative was
slammed by protesters and some
politicians the requirement was to come
into force at the end of this month but
has now been put on hold
we've looked at it properly and whilst
we should keep it in reserve as a
potential option i'm pleased to say that
we will not be going ahead with plans
for vaccine passports
these extraordinary times required
necessary but intrusive measures but i'm
determined to get rid of any powers we
no longer need because of our vaccine
defenses
well the decision was made despite a
recent rise in covert cases which
followed a short-term decline in
scotland though plans are still afoot to
make vaccine passports obligatory from
october and wales is also considering
the option passports and lockdown
restrictions are among the many measures
that have sparked outrage among brits
for a while
oh
[Applause]
well as for new lockdown restrictions
the english authorities do promise not
to reintroduce them in the near future
although boris johnson is soon to
announce a winter plan to speed up the
pace of vaccination and introduce
emergency measures if needed a senior
clinical lecturer we spoke to says
though that vaccine passports on their
own aren't enough and should be
complemented with other measures
a passport is only one thing it is a
piece of paper that says
you have been fully immunized no more no
less a fully immunized person can
nevertheless be infected and be
infectious to other people that's not
the way to
infection control a better way to
infection control is to do some
assessments are you infected are you
infectious rather than relying on a
piece of paper i can see that going
forward it is unlikely that we will need
a lockdown and a shutdown like we've had
if suddenly
unfortunately a variant were to arise
which was bypassing the vaccines which
was causing more severe disease we may
have to think of a different strategy
but at the moment
i can see how the secretary of state for
health and social care can get away with
saying we do not expect shutdowns again
you